sale sales sales something I told don't
talk about enough and very much the
foundation of my career or something I'm
gonna challenge myself in 2018 to talk
more about ski notes a little bit from
2016 but I think you can enjoy it
here's the full episode so for all you
sales people tag up your sales homie in
the comments and enjoy sit back
[Music]
who it is dark thank you so much for
that warm welcome excited about this I
think when I think about making
something happen in the world selling
something getting a donation getting
voted for whatever the transaction is I
always break down that world into sales
and marketing and I think that I spend a
lot of time these days in the marketing
funnel and really helping a lot of my
digital startups and my friends in
digital marketing
oh thank you so much good reaction to
the darkness Jets jersey that makes me
super happy I'm trying to convince a lot
of people go from sales to understand
the value of marketing but I'll tell you
right now through and through when I
when I pass away and they opened me up I
am a Salesman through and through and
I've been my whole life
big ups to the salespeople so coming to
a sales conference is a lot of fun for
me and I think there should be more of
them in our space because I think the
issue with a lot of my marketing friends
and people is it's very up in the clouds
and it doesn't really end up creating
the thing that I think we're all you
know tied to which is the transaction
what is the KPI like what are we
actually trying to do I'm gonna give you
a little background of where I came from
for the people in here that don't know
my story because I think it matters and
then I want to talk about what I would
do if I was in this audience I think
what I try to do as a salesman is I try
to reverse engineer I try to figure out
while on stage who the audience is I try
to figure out what Simon and Seth have
and Arianna and Frederick have already
said because I know they're spiels
really [ __ ] well and and I'm trying
to think about what can I say that's
different that is gonna actually bring
value and the truth is and I know those
four very well frederick i think is a
purebred salesman but i really do think
that i was born very lucky and then i
think my parents are very opposite and i
think i feel very in kinship with my
marketing and with my sales and so
that's what i want to focus on because i
think a lot of people here could make a
lot more money if they eliminated two
things one laziness to be very frank and
and to ideal
stick points of view of how they've made
their money in the past I think one of
the biggest concerns I have sitting here
in a world where I'm hungry to get one
to two people three people to get a lot
of value out of this talk is the way you
made your money before is my enemy the
way you've been successful yesterday is
my enemy
it is stunning if you understood what
runs through my head every morning on
how little I think anybody should give a
[ __ ] about anything I achieved yesterday
back you're really only as good as your
last at-bat and the thing that I'm most
passionate about I think many of you
guys and gals can agree with me on this
is the landscape of sales and all of
communication in our society has had a
fundamental shift over the last decade
because of technology and there's just a
lot of people that are doing things that
are not bringing them real value for
their actions my my religion in sales is
attention before I even think about how
to sell you my SAS product cuz it's
better than the one that you're using or
my wine or why you should use
vaynermedia and my agency or new pair of
sneakers or whatever you're selling in
this room mid market enterprise small
startup the one thing that connects us
is the end person's attention and this
is what I want to focus on it first my
career of being obsessed around
attention started when I was six and I'm
not kidding this is an interesting story
I was born in the Soviet Union I came
here as a kid my dad eventually got a
job as a stock boy in a liquor store in
New Jersey I originally lived in Queens
then I grew up in Edison New Jersey in
Edison when I was six and seven years
old I trekked manipulated sold I sold I
sold my friends on the idea of standing
behind a lemonade stand all day and so
when I was six years old
I had a six lemonade stand franchise in
Edison New Jersey how many of you
remember big wheels those little bikes
guys remember I still ride my big wheels
at the end of the day every summer and
pick up my cash like I was little Tony
Soprano or something
so it was a Salesman early on but it's
funny it wasn't the reason my friends
were behind the register selling the
lemonade and I was and it wasn't cuz I
was fancy it wasn't because I didn't
want to do the work it's because and
this is me now realizing this years
later it was because I was obsessed with
attention while my homies stood behind
the lemonade stands I walked up and down
the streets by the way for a lot of the
youngsters in here this was the 80s when
kids just went outside and did random
[ __ ] so I would walk I would I would
walk up and down the streets and
literally this sounds sick I am I would
sit at the cross-sections of streets
tinguely Lane in New Jersey
Inman Avenue in New Jersey I would sit
there and I would watch people I would
sit in for an hour I'm seven six seven
eight years old I would sit there for
hours and I would watch cars drive by
and I would try to see if I could see
their faces and I could figure out which
three or pull to put the lemonade stand
sign on because that would be the better
one because they would see it and buy
lemonade at early it was intuitive to me
at such a ridiculous age that the number
one asset was the attention and then
what I had to say is what mattered that
the creative that the product that the
copy' was the variable that the thing I
said on the other side of the phone was
the variable but before I could say it
no matter how good my game was did I
actually have their attention or was I
speaking to somebody that wasn't paying
attention I believe that the far
majority of this room has become
disconnected with the reality of the end
consumers attention that we have taken
for granted whether through laziness not
being compensated for it or whatever
other variable you are not being good at
what you do I don't know I believe that
the market of sales has lost its way
it's just I think it's the speed of
attention shift in today's society I
went on to have a very big baseball card
business when I was 12 and 13 when I was
12 13 I was selling baseball cards in
the malls of New Jersey and I was making
two to three thousand dollars a weekend
as a baseball card sale
I don't know about you guys but when you
have four when you're 14 and you have
$30,000 in cash under your bed and
you're not selling weed
you're a good [ __ ] salesman so that
was good by the way I plan on buying the
New York Jets which I think projected by
the time I'm ready is gonna cost me
between five and eight billion dollars
and I'm convinced that when I was 13 and
had $30,000 in cash it will be the
richest I've ever been and just couldn't
even begin to think about spending that
kind of money when I was 14 my dad
ruined my life
dragged me into the liquor store paid me
two bucks an hour to bag ice he now
owned his own store in Springfield New
Jersey and I went from like being my own
entrepreneur and doing my thing to
working in this store called shoppers
discount liquors that I hated because I
bagged ice for 15 hours a day and walked
home with 30 bucks
that was a bad those two or three years
were the dark ages of my professional
career when I was 16 17 I was allowed
upstairs I realized people collected
wine that was interesting to me because
I was into collecting and I embarked on
my career my career took an interesting
turn because I discovered the Internet
and in 1997 I launched one of the first
e-commerce wine businesses in America
called winelibrary.com I grew my dad's
business from a three to a sixty million
dollar business in five years I did it
through sales and marketing I did it in
two ways one I was out marketing
everybody by buying Google AdWords by
doing EEMA how many people here do email
marketing raise your hands in 1997 I had
a 200,000 person email database selling
wine that had 91.3% open rates right
yeah now it wasn't cuz I was such a hero
like that same list now is like 31.3
it's because nobody was doing it and the
thing that I want to talk to you about
is the stunning excuses that my salesman
friends make up for not doing snapchat
or Facebook or Twitter or Instagram or
LinkedIn content I love my sales friends
or like I do LinkedIn I'm like no no you
don't do LinkedIn you sit there and you
[ __ ] try to connect people and you're
a [ __ ] spam bot you [ __ ]
not a Salesman [ __ ] anyway sorry um
truth truth like I do LinkedIn sales no
you don´t you just click buttons and you
hope and pray and you control copy and
paste the same [ __ ] message to every
person because you're [ __ ] lazy
so anyway real estate when there's a new
vacation destination or a new town or
Hudson Yards is being built right here
the people that buy first if they're
right when you don't get the beachfront
property by waiting for years for what's
the value of it I am NOT I believe that
a purebred salesperson is never crippled
if her or his actions are not fruitful I
believe a purebred salesperson
understands that that's part of the game
that that's part of the hustle that
there's so much upside by doing a new
tactic even if you hit it once out of
every nine times the overall ROI of all
those hours becomes a net positive score
and that is why I think I've been
successful because my career in sales
has been predicated of not being
crippled by overworking to learn
something new
period it is it is insanity
and let me use that word aggressively it
is insanity for you to disrespect all
the social media platforms today and
what they can mean for sales for you you
have to understand if one person execute
transactions through it then you can -
the problem is it's hard the problem is
it takes time the problem is there's a
lot of easier ways to do it today but
those things go away anybody here that's
been doing email sales for 15 years
knows what I'm about to say which was 10
and 15 years ago it worked better right
it worked better because we play in one
game my friends all of us you're trying
to reach that person on the other end we
play in b2b arbitrage of attention it's
just supply and demand how many people
by show of hands is actually interesting
let's
with this let's establish that lying is
the devil and I have no interest in your
head nods I want full [ __ ] hands okay
here we go
how many people here now in 2016
actually actually hate it when another
person another human being
calls them raise your hand raise it high
I want people look around look around
raise it higher just real high please
these are human beings our fellow human
beings who actually hate when another
human being caused them let me tell you
why and then let me tell you why it's
important for this conversation
the reason they hate it is because time
has become the number one asset to every
person in this room the emerging pillar
in our society besides the health and
wellness of our family and money the
number one emerging pillar of value to
everybody in this room and everybody in
this conference and everybody outside is
time and calling somebody when they
weren't expecting it has now become
stealing ones time because we have the
alternative of when that person calls
you can say just text me just email me I
will call you back on my time it is my
belief that when I audit the sales
ecosystem and all the startups I'm
involved with and all the businesses I'm
involved with that salespeople steal
their clients time for their vested
interests instead of reverse engineering
the value of that person's time it is in
our best vested interest to send that
email it is in our best vested interest
to make that phone call
we are not reverse engineering the fact
that these people have become busy now
another thing that's extremely
fascinating for me being in this room is
I grew up in b2c my whole life right
only seven years ago when I started
vaynermedia did I go into the b2b world
just for the people that don't know here
I have a 650 person social digital
agency that have grown in last four
years from a 3 to a 100 million dollar
business in sales not [ __ ] valuation
and
by the way that's another conversation
for another [ __ ] day and I think the
thing that will be interesting to a lot
of people here is I've done that mainly
on not selling like we don't really do
RFPs I'm not interested in selling
somebody who I would tell you my number
like if somebody said what's your most
religious sales tactic it is not to try
to sell to somebody who's unsellable I
think one of the most fascinating things
that I bought it when I look at the
sales ecosystem is how much people take
time trying to convert somebody who's
unconverted all yes your product might
be eight thousand times better but if
that bosses boss is best friend homeys
with the alternative legacy software you
[ __ ] lost and then I watch people
think that they're gonna convert it on
merit
there's no [ __ ] merit there's just
human beings making human decisions and
I think we need to get a lot less
romantic about that and start being much
more practical about the ecosystem let
me tell you another way that I've grown
that business that I think as instead of
pontificating and cursing up here let me
give you a direct tactic that I think a
lot of you guys can use a couple books
ago because I decided to write those
kind of things I wrote a book called the
Thank You economy it's super interesting
to me it's the notion of if you provide
so much upfront value to an individual
can you actually guilt them into buying
[ __ ] especially if all your actions are
predicated on not expecting them to buy
it that's the big part when the energy
of your tactics is to convert you will
lose when your energy is to
disproportionately bring value and let
the chips fall where they may you will
win it will change your behavior it will
change the energy of the execution let
me give you a story vaynermedia there
was a certain CMO that I really wanted
to get to because I wanted their
business right I don't like doing rfp's
because it's a crapshoot and we're not
very good at them right and I have the
fortune nature of having a brand so a
lot of business comes to me but this one
wasn't and I wanted it so I decided to
follow and this is my number one number
one tactic for every person this room
that I am positive that if you actually
put in the work and do it that you will
email me and this is really the reason
I'm giving this is because I want you to
email me in four months be like hey bran
I saw you in New York at the sales
machine conference I figured a little
bit ridiculous but I did this thing and
it actually worked
cool thanks that's it that's what I want
and here's the tactic how many people
here are in b2b sales raise your hand
awesome coming from B to C and now being
in b2b and being part of companies like
Buddy Media and percolated and wildfire
that we've had successful exits in and
watching the landscape of sales in that
environment I've done very well most my
b2b investments I am stunned how much
easier it is to be a b2b salesman than a
b2c salesman you literally know the name
of the [ __ ] person you're selling to
this is a big deal this is a big deal
because by knowing the name in 2016 you
have the opportunity to use big data in
your advantage on a micro level to
create the world that you want let me
explain
I found the CMO that I wanted on Twitter
some of the people that you're trying to
get to won't be on Twitter they may be
on LinkedIn they may be on Facebook they
may be on Instagram but the fun part is
60 to 70 percent of your prospects are
on one of these platforms and putting
out data publicly on what they like and
what they're into I followed this
individual and I noticed that he was a
humongous st. Louis Cardinals baseball
fan this is what my plan went into
action I started watching everything he
was tweeting about ironically I would
you know I'm like a cobra in the grass
I'll tell you the number one thing that
I think really separates good
salespeople
from bad salespeople is patience I'm
patient as [ __ ] right so I was staying
in the grass just waiting
collecting content being patient really
mapping what he's into paying attention
ironically it coincided with my fantasy
baseball league right so I'm in my
fantasy baseball draft I've got the team
I want I've got a couple of empty slots
on the reserve thing I'm like you know
what I'm gonna I'm gonna draft this
up-and-coming rookie Cardinals player
for many other reasons than just winning
my fantasy baseball team so I drafted
got anybody any Cardinals fans in here
and he coupled maybe two or three
I drafted a guy by name of kolten Wong
infielder for the st. Louis Cardinals
before he was even in Major League
Baseball and so then I wait and I wait
for kolten Wong to get up to the major
leagues and I wait for kolten Wong to do
something good and then I see what I
needed to him tweeting about kolten Wong
which allowed me to jump into that tweet
and say hey I'm kolten Wong on my
fantasy team isn't he awesome and he
replied yeah he's awesome that's it
patience remember don't close on the
first date all right so we interact a
little bit more about the Cardinals
they're making their playoff run and
somewhere about three weeks later he
tweets me back and says hey I see that
you're CEO of a digital agency we're
thinking about you know maybe changing
up our roster a little bit is this
something we could talk about with sure
[ __ ] Ken
[Applause]
I want to give you real data here less
than an hour of work being patient
spread off of probably about four months
I was able to convert that strategy into
a three point six million dollar paying
client write sales sales but sales not
that look like here's a blank email that
I'm gonna blast everybody is obsessed
with scalability everybody is obsessed
with scalability and all the action in
sales is scaling the unscalable I
believe that sales even in today's
environment is still a very face-to-face
game right I think a lot of us agree
with that
I think the biggest disconnect from the
people that just heard that in this room
that have done that their whole lives
that were like yeah hell yeah is that
they don't realize that technology is
now the scaleable gateway drug to the
human interactions I sell I'm going to
Cleveland right now after this there's a
basketball game I want to see and I'm
gonna sell on that plane on the way
there because I'm using technology
Twitter Facebook LinkedIn and these
platforms as a gateway drug to create an
interpersonal relationship there are
people I know very well that I've spent
very little time with in real life but I
do that through those channels and then
when we see each other there's a total
different feeling I have for these three
individuals these are people I could
never even have a relationship with
without this technology these are people
that I haven't met more than once but I
feel enormous kinship towards them and
the dude with the jet jersey because
because I've put in this sales work why
do you go golfing with a client why do
you eat a [ __ ] steak with a client
why didn't go to networking events you
do it to create context at scale you do
it to create context the absolute closer
and the enabler and the jabbing and the
flirter and the the bad essence of
energy is context right if you know that
girls you know boyfriend if you know
their interest in the Cardinals you have
a leg up on the comp
addition it's why you spent time with
your clients and the decision makers and
the influencers of the decision makers
because you are building context what
technology today does and these five or
six platforms that are the current state
of social media do all at the fingertip
of your phone when you're going to take
a piss or fly in a Cleveland or whenever
you want ultimately scalable you can do
it anytime 6 p.m. 1 a.m. whenever you
want however you roll you get up early
you get up late you can hustle in these
platforms and create context and the
fact of the matter is and almost nobody
does it nobody does it because they lack
patience they sure do you know how many
of you in this room have a point of view
on what Facebook or LinkedIn or Twitter
can do for your business
and you've never used the [ __ ]
product it's real thanks for that one
clap I liked it and so we live in 2016
in a world where the majority of you
when you live like a normal human being
and don't put on your sales outfit for
the day would never convert on the
actions that you take as a sales person
during the work day the amount of you
that delete every [ __ ] email that you
get that is a bulk email the amount of
you that will never answer that phone
the amount of you that would net who
here is super fired up to go home and go
through their direct mail carefully and
so I'm fascinated by the disconnect of
who you are as a human being and how you
act when it's in your vested financial
interest for another human being to act
the way you want because it's more
convenient for you
that is the arbitrage and that will
always be the arbitrage forever
so many of you have done business
because of word-of-mouth right how many
people here have landed more business
because of word-of-mouth from a prior
transaction raise your hands if you
didn't raise your hand you just don't
[ __ ] understand or you're lazy and
that's [ __ ] interesting too
when I think about social media all I
think about it as is as the plumbing of
word-of-mouth in our society I'm
fascinated by how much business I do
with somebody after I actually sell them
and what I do with them to create that
word-of-mouth versus what I did to get
them in the first place the enormous
amount of energy that we all deploy as
salespeople to get the business versus
what we do with that business even if
it's handed off to an account person if
you were that point of reference your
ability to stay in that ecosystem and
bring value is it incredible and again I
implore you to understand the value of
public data let me give you a b2c
scenario but you can deploy this in your
own world Wine Library before
Thank You economy I wanted an example
for my keynotes about how I was doing
the Thank You economy so I was very
passionate about having somebody buy
something on wine library that was
inexpensive and then overwhelming them
with a gift
based on their big data I love sports so
no question this is another sports story
guy buys a case of Pinot Grigio for a
hundred eleven dollars we made 17 bucks
and profit on the case we had to find
people with unusual names because we had
to find them on Twitter and this was
still 2011 so finally we found one they
were having a tough time finding people
on Twitter that were buying wine for the
first time I wanted a first time
customer guy buys a case of Pinot Grigio
in Chicago we made 11 bucks they find
him he has an unusual name like
Vaynerchuk you know we find him it's
definitely him and we looked and we find
his Twitter his whole Twitter stream is
about Jay Cutler the quarterback of the
Chicago Bears just tons of Jay Cutler I
love you Jay Cutler there's that a great
I tell the Thank You Department which is
something we have at Wine Library which
is not customer service its offense
customer services defense but thank you
Department kicks in and we go and buy
him a $350 Jersey signed by Jay Cutler
and we send it to him
ROI negative on that transaction I think
we can all agree
and so now I'm pumped we finally found
somebody we sent it I'm you know my
keynotes are coming up I'm gonna have a
great
studies gonna buy a lot of wine he's
gonna do something it's gonna be
unbelievable I can't wait to tell all of
you three weeks go by [ __ ]
didn't get get back to us so I'm like
what the [ __ ]
I'm grateful [ __ ] so nothing I'm like
calling four times a day I'm like you
sure like I know it's in spam like get
the IT department I'm like this is
impossible nothing I'm boarding a plane
to Orlando I get a phone call Gary like
yeah they're like we got something I'm
like finally I'm like what did he do
better look okay better they're like
listen to this I'm like okay we just got
an order from Plano Texas I'm like okay
for $6,000 worth of red burgundy I'm
like great
now that's great but wait till you hear
the note in the order like cool dear why
my brain first of all what a great red
burgundy selection you have make sure
you don't ship this it's hot here hold
it for a while
ship it when it's cooler next PS you
sent my friend John a Bears jersey the
other day when he bought some wine from
you
PSS I'm a huge Bruce Springsteen fan
[Applause]
for very little money and for a solid
amount of effort you could go home from
this conference and go through your
entire rolodex of everybody that you
sold something to in the last year go on
social media look at their data and do
something that shows effort let me tell
you what's not effort the at scale
handwritten note that wasn't handwritten
it was just a tactic to fake effort what
about actual effort what about actually
sending me something about the Jets or
Rubio or Lionel Richie because it's very
easy to figure out I like those three
things what people are under estimating
is the word-of-mouth ecosystem that we
actually live in because this thing has
changed our behavior I don't know if
you've noticed but we now have all
defaulted into this amazing notion that
we should tell the world everything
about everything always about all
everything it's what we do for some
reason everybody needs to know our two
cents on the game last night and where
the world's going this is what we do we
share now you may not like it it's the
reality of the marketplace and one thing
that people share more than anything is
when they are caught off guard or that
they can feel that somebody gave them
more effort than the market my belief is
that the greatest version of a person in
the world is a purebred salesperson let
me tell you why my definition one man's
definition of a purebred salesperson is
one that is obsessed with providing more
value to the other person than they ask
for in return when you make that mental
shift and more importantly when your
actions start speaking that things start
to massively unlock I have built both my
very large businesses on one backbone
which is I want to know what this
person's gonna say at my funeral I have
no interest in selling in something I
don't believe I know for a fact that
there is a staggering percentage of
people here as they become
educated in the market they sell in that
they actually do not believe that their
product is the best I could not function
in that environment I'm not judging you
we all have our different paths and
different things loans mortgages respect
not trying to go there but I would tell
you that when you fully believe in what
you sell through and through it gets a
hell of a lot easier when you actually
give a [ __ ] about the other person more
than you it gets triple easy it gets
triple easy my friends and so I implore
all of you to understand that we are
living through a marketplace now where
our consumers have more information than
ever you're not gonna win a deal on
inefficiency of information of our
consumer and so I implore you to start
producing two things one leading with
the heart and reverse engineering what
your end consumer whether they bought
from you or their your prospect what
makes them tick above and beyond being
the decision maker of your [ __ ]
product and number two start thinking
about the people you've sold to after
you've sold to them and understand what
they can mean to your business by you
actually caring about them as well
because they're still valuable to you
even though you hooked up got it cool
I'd like to spend the rest of my time
very honestly with you on QA so I know
that the mics are back there so if you
guys can start lining up I'll wait for
people to get back there and please
don't be shy is the part so I don't like
the mics that stand I like to move it
around I find people are lazy don't just
want to walk back here but please go
there I'd love to get far more detailed
those are my fundamental principles on
on sales I think it's stunning how many
people have not recognized that
technology doesn't replace the way we
all sold technologies enabling the scale
of how we all sold and I think that's
probably if you asked me what I wanted
to leave with more than anything it's
that because I'm I feel like I fly all
around the country to close my deals I
want to be in the goddamn room I don't
even like Skype like I lose the context
I need to feel the energy but the amount
of work that I do to get on third and a
half base through Facebook Twitter
Instagram is remarkable and the context
I have on the levers that I need to pull
in that room
[ __ ] sold before I [ __ ] got there you
like that
thanks man that was a good way to thank
you all right the big part what's your
name my man my name is Sean show me
clearly well you inspired me to leave my
corporate job to create my own business
because according to you I'm 25 I'd be
[ __ ] stupid to stay in my corporate
job I believe that so I followed what
you said but deal do you have the chops
to pull it off well I've been doing it a
year and I've been making more money
working for myself taking Tuesday off
and working on a Saturday because I took
the risk Mazel Tov thank you good for
you
all right Joe rally turned me on to so
she's standing right I see I see so I
got to give her the credit are you gonna
are you are you willing to kick her a
little Commission everything's
negotiable
she made me read one of your books
before I worked for her go ahead right
now I hope sales and marketing work
together and yeah the things is sales
managers they want KPIs like a small
touches yes makes sense yes one thing I
have to Kate for like the social selling
is using LinkedIn touches okay instead
of call metrics yeah they're against it
and what you're talking about even
pushing that further right using
LinkedIn Twitter or other tools but the
corporate sales people and even
marketing managers and directors VP's
they don't want to go that way they
still want 150 calls a day
yes so how do you incentivize them or
say hey you got abandon the old kpi's
allow them there's only one way the CEO
of that company has to change the
incentives let me let me tell you how
quickly you can get a sales force to do
it from every single thing that is wrong
at vaynermedia is one billion percent my
fault right it's run from the top you
can get a sales force to get involved in
social tomorrow make the KPIs around
that if you actually incentivize the
behavior they will do it one thing I
love about us me being a sales result
we're [ __ ] easy like we are reverse
engineering how we get our [ __ ]
bonuses and our money
blindly if tomorrow your company said if
you send out a thousand tweets that are
not automated by hand and that's how you
make your bonus you're sending a
thousand tweets not by hand and that's
how you're making your [ __ ] bonus so
the answer to your question my man is
it's not in the middle it's not in the
upper middle
it's the gal and the guy at the top that
has to change all the rules to the
behavior of the sales organization and
it happens really [ __ ] quick I'll
tell you this is gonna throw you for a
loop I have forced some of my startups
to add more calling in as a KPI because
they want to go completely automated and
Technology and they disrespect the phone
now do I think the phone is losing and
conversion yes I do I think it's it's
behavior in the market do I think it's
zero absolutely not do I think it's
silly to just have one move yes I do
awesome thank you thank you Beth thank
you my man over here Oh Gary how are you
man
great man big fan of your snapchat
channel thank you for that watch all the
time Thank You Man so from Gainesville
Florida big tech scene there yeah John
Spence speaker he's from there to you
yep no test to it so I like I like using
business as a force for good good so
that's like what I've been doing my
entire life so here's here's this thing
that we're doing now we do microfinance
loans okay for needy entrepreneurs yes
in East Africa okay through cultural
tourism and we doing a 0% interest I
love it
so that's take it off it's number one to
interpret visor calm and Lonely Planet
guide book now yep so we're getting all
the choice but the other thing what you
do is we do have a site called shake and
I thought work okay we do a mentoring
for k-12 students to get them interested
in STEM fields yes by partnering them
with hiring students teachers classrooms
and families with NASA scientists early
career scientists it's great virtually
around the world okay and that's taken
off and that's partnership which call
second foundation SS Republic
so here's my new business idea and I
want your blessing or your criticism of
it so I just acquired my dream house you
did right before coming here I was in
Montreal without the Gainesville Florida
sign a piece of paper and flute right
back up here this nation actually thank
you thanks to congratulations thank you
it's a beautiful Victorian from 1903 I'm
gonna turn you thank you no three is a
great year it is what's right if you
have some wine from 1903 it let's rock
it in there I wish so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna turn it into a boutique
hotel okay 10,000 per night okay to stay
there okay it's gonna be donation its
but to my 501c3 yep
so everything that gets donated in your
fee for staying there becomes a 100
percent donates for 501 C 3 tax
write-off and then I use it entirely I
don't take any salary from it to do good
in the rough okay and on top of that
we're gonna we have our buddies that
have car rental companies for exotic
cars I got guys yep other friends that
have jet leasing companies yep so what
we're gonna do is a bespoke sorta system
where you're gonna have the billion
dollar package okay where you can for 1
billion dollars watch for the Sun on
IndieGoGo or 1 billion dollars you can
buy a room in the house and you can give
it to your kid and for that we'll fly
you from where you are in the world to
us for and then we'll show you what
we're doing with your money yep and then
we'll take you anywhere I don't really
want to go to see it in action and then
we'll bring you also back to Gainesville
and we'll show you go put it in touch
with thought leaders scientists anything
like this happen I grow and make that
happen
again it's a billion dollar donation and
anybody anybody who doesn't think that's
cool
there's being silly I love it sweet cool
and I'm it's a blessing and I'll take a
get when the Ranger schedule comes out
this is a Montreal right
the house is in Florida so go halves
this it again so got it well I don't
want to go there okay and I'll also take
a night in the 10,000 dollar hotel send
it Cheers cool man yes here hi hey thank
you for the talk Gary I have a question
sure it's like you and beyond
we all have 24 hours a day yes and
knowing that time is valuable and if you
do your due diligence with clients how
do you with your inbound leads vet and
qualify them to know how you can get
killer clients on your roster
I own a digital marketing agency
intuitively yeah well this is like and
have you got my other question in case
you answered that really quick can you
tell us a story about if you did your
due diligence and you've sent the $350
jersey and all of that and you get to
the very end and then you lost business
or a client like lost doesn't we didn't
get it closed and lost yeah and then any
business closed had it and then lost it
you pitched it and you got really far
and then it was a closed happens all the
time yeah just fundamentally not
crippled by it and just knew like I've
never thought about that in my entire
life yeah I think the biggest reason
people lose is they spend all their
[ __ ] time thinking about that and I
don't give a [ __ ] yeah perfect I mean
it's it's the truth by the way like like
on a very serious kick and I think a lot
of you are getting it dwelling dwelling
on a loss micro analyzing why it
happened it happened because of 750,000
different random ship things that you
put enough controlled or because you
[ __ ] up neither one of them is really
that valuable to think about I'm just on
to the next one thanks you're welcome
it's true again there's some things that
I believe in like in purebred sales and
purebred entrepreneurship that have
clearly gone awry in the last half
decade to a decade like if you're a
salesperson and you guys all know this
is why you're here I mean you're here
you're not scared of the loss you're not
crippled by the loss now some of you are
more crippled than others I think the
most successful the bunch are just
literally on face it's insane to me how
I was scared that I was gonna have to
recall one for you that's how little I
remember them and they happen every
[ __ ] month we lose pitches all the
time and I'm like they're just stupid
[ __ ] people because we're the best
that's what I think okay I know my name
is Seaton Wilkins and yeah thanks for
the talk I can relate to you in a lot of
ways one just being because I came from
a b2c world yes and now I'm gonna be to
be world yes there's a lot of different
things and I think a lot of the themes
that we've talked about in this Congress
as a whole and one of things we brought
up is just kind of caring about that
other person on the other side of the
table right so what I one of the things
I keep trying to think about is like how
do we teach that to other people as well
because I genuinely am interested in
people I genuinely love to help people
yes and that's kind of my philosophy on
sales but we're all incentivized on that
dollar like how we make our own money
which is necessary and I completely get
that as we should be but how do you then
teach someone empathy and actually
caring genuinely asking how are you and
actually the answer I don't know other
than telling every sales person this
room go reverse engineer the 500 best
salespeople you've ever heard of or no
and every one of them has the same
[ __ ] stick which is they play a
marathon instead of a sprint they deploy
empathy ingratitude they're more patient
I don't know how to teach those things
when it's so in everybody's face it is
so in everybody's face it's just hard
it's hard to be patient because you want
a new [ __ ] watch like like it's just
real like I don't know and very honest
with you I do it I put out content that
scale but I really don't give a [ __ ] if
any of you take it and go use it like I
really don't like I can't come to your
house and make you do it like and and by
the way it's called meritocracy and
capitalism the people that do it win and
the ones that still think there's some
[ __ ] short-term system that they're
gonna be the one person that's gonna
figure it out and crush in sales they
don't win as much as it should be cool
hey guys d-roc here T Brock is here he's
right there
do you rock stand up dear ah to the man
do you want to rock the little puck 4d
rock is he's been shooting Garry live so
giggles dailyvee let's super badass
I appreciate let's talk about it we
talked about sales today I believe in
marketing and branding I put out a daily
vlog two three times a week that follows
me around it shows the stories of being
an entrepreneur people watch it they
like it and then they want to do
business with me it's not super
complicated like so so if you put out
content you know it's one thing to do
surprise and delight the Jets jersey
things in a nature what about if you
actually put out videos or audios or
written articles about your stories and
how you were a good salesperson or your
best things or it's how do you bring
value I bring value to people my
ecosystem I want zero in return because
I know the network effect creates the
return so I run a DJ entertainment
agency we do events all over the city
yes and also digital marketing
consulting yes you inspire me to
actually film kind of a day in the life
I just shot it on Sunday loved it
and I think I like to think I live a
very interesting life worth sharing I
think I think so you know I think
reality TV and voyeurism and human
behavior proves we all do like everybody
the whole 15 minutes of fame thing is
now that everybody's famous to 15 people
the markets gonna decide how interesting
you are you're gonna either be
interesting to a million people or 74
but it's clearly got an opportunity it
sounds like you answered it before I
even ask the questions what I'd like to
do but you know pretty much time some
valuable what advice would you give to
somebody that really hasn't created a
lot of video content has some following
I'll just limit just live it like nobody
wants anything that's manipulated right
like just do you like you may think it's
interesting I may not it doesn't matter
the easiest thing to do is to be
yourself it's also the hardest thing to
do right and so I would tell you as
somebody who loses you know how I've
lost business I cursed in a board
meeting and somebody was very
conservative and said let's not give
business to that [ __ ] right so
so like but that's okay because Irene
net-net and I will tell you that it's
really the one thing I can't do is not
be myself it's been the thing that has
absolutely separated me from the pact
thank you
you got it I'm gonna speak one more in
let's do it last question I'm so sorry
they're like buzzing me here
go ahead darlin but you gave me up on
Twitter I promise Lancer hi Gary
I work for a non-profit and I know
you've you've done a lot of work with
nonprofits as well yes what we we rely
tremendously on volunteers yes we're
trying to monetize that volunteering
we're showing companies there's a value
to that and translate that to charitable
contributions how do we honor them do
you have any ideas of how we can honor
that contribution of volunteering but
also you know surprise them to light
those potential you know customers
essentially these corporations that have
these charitable contributions to give
in a way that makes sense for a
non-profit I I want to make sure I'm
following this right give me a little
bit more context like go a little more
detail what do you guys do so we sell
opportunities for employee engagement so
team-building yes and so volunteering
but a lot of companies they say well
we're already giving their time why do
you want to also have a charitable
contribution whereas the reality is
there's a cost to running these events
and there's also a value to these and
then I see and that what those employees
are doing is actually something
charitable yes so they write so you're
not taking them to softball games that
group is team building around doing
something charitable exam so the
organization thinks you're almost double
dipping yes yes challenging for sure
so I think you know as I think about
that what I I reverse engineer I think
one of the things you need to think a
whole lot about is the ROI of a cohesive
unit and retention something I'm very
passionate about is emotional
intelligence versus IQ right I think one
thing to really businesses are funny
they like money so the first place I
would go is to run a report or analyze
what actually happens to the retention
of their employees if they actually do
this if you told me as the CEO of
vaynermedia that a on top of giving you
my people during their work hours to
build a home that I have to give you
$10,000 but you're gonna save me 27,000
because 2.7 of my employees are gonna
stay for a year longer and I'm not gonna
have to spend money on recruiting and
replacement cost because when that's the
ethos go there the biggest problem is
people get to the reason I've been
successful on the boards in NGO and you
know of my work is because I've brought
business DNA to the nonprofit sector
like let's eliminate the romance don't
tell me the fluff tell me that I'm gonna
save 17,000 dollars a year by giving you
25,000 and I'll write you 50,000 got it
thank you so much you're welcome thank
you guys I'm sorry well I'm sorry thank
you bye guys salespeople leave you two
cents on what you just heard we'd love
to get your comments let me know
[Music]